this was in January 2017 we were
literally
crushed under the under the weight of
our my sequel database you were running
out of this space we could barely get
through a day's worth of transactional
volume and Netflix just kept adding more
members we had known we had no idea what
to do we were you know were you running
out of ideas we faced a very uncertain
future and this is us in July 2018 our
application is now running on Cassandra
we have horizontal scalability we have
fault tolerance we have performance and
we are firmly in control of her future
I'm Rahul Palani I'm gonna talk about
building financial systems on eventually
consistent databases this is mostly
about our journey from my sequel to
Cassandra but a lot of the things that
we did you can learn and apply to other
eventually consistent databases as well
which are similar in current
characteristics yeah practically
everyone knows that fix but we're an
online video streaming provider we have
130 million customers worldwide
practically in every country except
China and Korea my team building
engineering we do subscription billing
for Netflix we figure out who to charge
and when to charge so if you're supposed
to be charged on the fifth of the month
I mean our our team's job is to make
sure that it's the fifth not the fourth
not the sixth it's the fifth we also do
financial reporting so what that means
is given that you know we charged say
four million customers get yesterday we
roll that up in a report a grenade and
send it over to our financial guys who
eventually reported to Wall Street so
we're like a sock system and stuff like
that we also manage gift cards and
balances so if you apply a gift card to
your account my team is the one that
manages that state as you can imagine to
do all this we rely on many micro
services some of them are offline like
the subscription billing part that
figures
who the charge I can take it downtown
but the ones that you know report the
seed of the customer to our upstream
services whether they could whether
they've paid or not and consequent
consequently whether they can be charged
or not those have to be online and not
only just online they have to be fault
tolerant now you might think that it's
billing why does this billing to be
available you know as long as I can
stream
who cares of whether you know I paid or
not consider the scenario you report
your credit card store so no Netflix can
no longer charge you and it's Friday
night you want to catch up on your
favorite news show but you've stopped
your streaming and so you say no problem
I'll update my credit card and I can
start streaming again so you go online
you try to update your credit card and
you see something like this in this
moment at this point we failed you we've
come between you and your favorite piece
of content we never want to be in this
position we never want to be the reason
why you can't stream Netflix Netflix has
also grown crazy for the past ten years
we've grown more than 10x and when we
set out to build our new system on
Cassandra we looked at this and we knew
that whatever new system we built had to
be scalable had to grow with our Netflix
is growing Netflix as a whole operates
in multiple regions for availability
reasons if we detect a problem in one of
the region's we seamlessly shift traffic
from one region to another and our
members don't even notice and the
problems can be different right like it
could be you know we did a deployment
and suddenly stuffs breaking no problem
we shift could even more recently you
had case where hurricane Florence was
heading us this one and we shifted
traffic and no one was affected we
wanted to be multi-region available like
the rest of Netflix but we were on my
sequel and my sequel is decidedly single
mast
there are other options like Aurora but
they're multi hazy but not multi vision
being on my sequel and a single master
database means you also have a single
point of failure and there are ways to
kind of deal with it a couple of them is
using read replicas and you're having a
warm standby to failover to and there
were still problems with those consider
this kind of topology where we have read
replicas in other regions and we do a
read write in one region what we saw in
practice was if there was a heavy load
on the master or some networking issues
between the regions you could get steel
reads and now you're serving steel state
to our customers so they applied a gift
card and they're certainly not seeing on
their website and you get a lot of csgo
the other strategy of using slave
promotions and imagine the scenario
where you have a master and three slaves
you promote the slave that's in your
local region and now you've lost all
three or other slaves and you have to
rebuild those slaves from scratch with
art case we had like terabytes of data
and rebuilding that would take days and
in that time with one master and no
slaves we were vulnerable we couldn't
survive another failure in that time so
we wanted to get rid of this situation
as well we needed something better we
wanted something that was fault tolerant
something that could grow with how
Netflix was growing we needed something
that allowed us to switch regions and if
there was a failure we could recover
quickly
Cassandra fit the bill it was
horizontally scalable it's multi master
and its fault tolerant there are there
were other benefits for using Cassandra
Cassandra is widely deployed at Netflix
so we have a lot of experience to fall
back on Cassandra is also well
integrated into our big data system so
we could use those tools we have an
internal team
that manages deploys patches Cassandra
so we could rely on them for DevOps
because if you want to use your own
database at Netflix you have to do your
own data DevOps and finally the thing
that allowed us to use Cassandra was the
support for atomic compare and said that
that had just just matured but it's not
perfect
especially not for a financial system
it's eventually consistent it lacks
transactions so you can not roll there's
no rollback you have to manage your
rollback yourself it's not relational so
coming from a traditional database
system where we had relations this was
kind of a mismatch and finally one of
the main thing that we did was financial
reporting and financial reporting or
aggregate reporting is simply not
supported on Cassandra and definitely
it's kind of supported but it's
definitely not recommended so how do you
build something that's that's a
financial system on Cassandra well so
for eventually consistent and lack of
transactions we use something we use the
good atomic components add primitives
like with transactions for not having
relational schema we wrote our entire
relation in one row finally for not
having aggregate crying abilities we
simply replicated our rights to another
data store and we did our OLAP queries
and aggregate courage from there let's
dive into these a little bit more
consistency like the transactions
what I like the transactions they are
not transactions they're completely
missed named they're actually atomic
compared and set primitives what does
that mean so if you do an insert you can
say only let that insert succeed if that
ID does not exist so you can say if not
exists and if you do an update you can
say only that update succeed if a volume
a particular column is a particular
value so you can say update if X is
goodbye
it's available since Cassandra 2.0 and
the way they're implemented is Cassandra
implemented its own version of paxos on
top of it which actually took four
different round trips to complete one
right to the database let's look at how
we implemented updates so the Divi the
way we do the updates was using
optimistic locking consider a schema
like this where you have an ID column a
name and a version column
the first thing you do is you select
from that select from the row that you
want to write to and so you select star
from widgets variety equals one and now
you know the version that that row is in
the database currently it says version
one next you issued the update you say
update widgets set name equal to bar
increment the version to do where ID is
equal to 1 only if the version in the
database is what I read just a second
ago and so there are two scenarios that
can happen that it succeeds because the
version in the database was one and you
were successfully able to override it
with two and the second one is the
update fails because someone overrode
that row
while you were processing it and so you
get an applied equal to false and you
have to retry actually I lied there's a
third scenario your update can succeed
in your region and another beacon
succeed in another region and now you're
kind of screwed
with Cassandra last right wins and so if
one region contains one right and the
other region contains the other they
will eventually reconcile and which one
will win its own time stamp if bar was
written first bar is the one that will
override everything bass was written
first bass will overwrite everything why
does this happen
well it's happened because of a design
choice that we made we chose to use
local quorum as our consistency level
and local quorum ensures a dhama city
only within a region so if you if you
have cross region rights to the same key
at the same time you're kind of on your
own why did we use local chrome why
didn't we want to get into this kind of
situation to see that let's step back a
little bit and see how cassandra does
fault-tolerance the way we the the we
Cassandra does fault-tolerance is by
replicating rights and it's called the
replication factor you can say replicate
my rights to three different nodes so
that you know if one node goes down I
can rely on the other two off the three
nodes that you write to the right should
succeed on a quorum of nodes as the
majority of the nodes so this is an
example the diagram shows a local quorum
in which the right is going to three
nodes but it's relying only on an act
from two of them and the client was
given the success there are various
levels that you can configure Cassandra
to I'm going to talk about a local
quorum and each quorum which is the
global consistency level and each quorum
means Cassandra will expect a quorum of
nodes to acknowledge the rights in every
region and so you can see that you know
it's fanning out to every region for
every drive now I mentioned that
Cassandra uses its own version of paxos
which has four different round trips in
this scenario now you've blown up your
round trips to twelve essentially
instead of four if you have three
regions
and so Paxos across regions is really
expensive your average case will be 12x
your 99 percentile will be crazy because
some note somewhere is failing so in
order to keep leading C's low we chose
local quorum but it's a trade-off
we gave up global consistency for
latency let's jump back to insert how
does insert work well we cannot use
optimistic locking because there's no
row in the database yet to check the
version off but you can still use the
atomic component set parameters you can
say if not exists whenever in order to
have that you need to know the ID
beforehand what we do is for a given
payload that we need to write to the
database we figure out an invariant we
say you know in our case what it meant
was did I remember was a member was
supposed to be charged only once for a
given month so we used that as an
invariant and said there should not be
any other row for the same month in the
database and so we we took those data
columns we hashed them up using UUID v5
and we generated key using that and we
used that as an invariant the reason why
we needed this was mainly because we
used sqs for delivering those payloads
to our application and SQS Garin
gandhi's at least one still every and so
you can get this into the situation
where you have duplicate delivery and
you have to kind of counteract that
but this doesn't prevent something like
double-click or those kind of scenarios
so this is an example of that you know
if you have a system like a shopping
cart system you can hash the product
code values the cart ID that was used at
a time into a single UID v5 and get that
and as I was mentioning like it wouldn't
protect against like a double click send
so with this scheme there's something to
consider
you know cassandra is really fast at
riding it's built for a lighter
transactions we'll make that at least
four times slower and you have to do
that read before writing anyways so all
of those will add up so if you need the
raw write capabilities
this will definitely slow you down when
those four round trips are going on it
could happen that the coordinator node
fails on the final step so all of the
nodes have acknowledged the write the
write has actually succeeded but you get
a failure so you have to keep in mind
that each quorum is really expensive and
if used local quorum you can get
clobbering direct so you have to deal
with that as well and finally we could
use inserts and the scheme of using
invariants because we had an invariant
so your system needs some kind of
invariant to generate those IDs so
that's what we did to handle coordinator
right time ons
we actually if you get a right timeout
we check again
we read again and check if the row
actually exists in the form that we want
in the database and only if it doesn't
exist we throw that failure back to the
client if you get an atomic write
failure like an applied equal to false
you simply throw it back and you have to
retry and the transaction from the start
and you know do all the invariant checks
that your system needs you have to
ensure that a right to a given key is
happening only in one region at a given
point of time of course it can happen
across regions in at different points of
time the ravine and we ran into this
when you first built the system and so
the way we solved it what we were doing
earlier was that we were writing in one
region and then rewriting to SQS and
then processing that write in another
region
and that was the thing so it's not just
a customer doing an interaction the same
interaction in different region it was
we who were interacting with that row
while the customer was interacting in
another region and so to prevent that
what we did we moved all of the
processing in the region that the right
originated in and that solves a lot of
that issue for us and finally you have
to generate an ID based on those
invariants so that you can prevent
things like duplicate insertion on sqs
delivery if you're still paranoid which
we were you can still do more what we
did was on every ride we would replicate
that right to Kafka and every night we
would take a snapshot of Cassandra and
upload it to hi and then we would
compare those ride events to that
snapshot and see if they agree or not
and we did catch a lot of
inconsistencies and fixed a lot of bugs
using this where we would see a write
being a different state than what the
snapshot told us wasn't not having a
relational schema now we were billing
system that was coming from my sequel so
a lot of our data model was relational
it had we had an invoice we had a
customer who had many voices and who and
who have you know many line items on an
on an invoice and you know modeling that
as a key value structure and flattening
it out would have made programming on
the on the application harder so we
didn't want to get in get that there was
another constraint if you want to use
atomic compare and set parameters in
Cassandra it doesn't allow multi-column
family right so you couldn't have
relations in different column families
and have like a single transaction
wrapping that even multi Dro atomic
rights are not recommended by Kassam
Cassandra because simply they're more
expensive now
more nodes need to be engaged in a
single ride so what did we do
we built a poor-man's relational schema
on top of Cassandra
we took our entire object word object
tree and we flattened out the top-level
object was flattened out into columns in
Cassandra but the child relations were
serialized to JSON and stored as strings
in in the column so if you had invoice
and invoice items inverse items was just
adjacent blob inside the invoice content
it's very important to understand the
carriage characteristics of your
database and the different you know
datatypes that it provides cassandra has
this helpful data type called collection
data bug types it has sets Maps lists
and initially we were using that but we
found out that the way it stores it is
it stores the each value as an
individual column inside the collection
and so it blows it out and so in
practice reading and writing those are
expensive so what we reverted back to
was if we have a month one-to-many
relation we just realized that as a JSON
array and stored as a single JSON blob
in the top-level column family now you
might look at this and say this looks a
little clunky it doesn't fit Cassandra
perfectly and you're right it does but
it and you know you you lose the ability
to do crud operations on an individual
child relation you know properties and
there's no schema enforcement on your
child relations but there are some good
things as well it's less simpler it
works really well with Cassandra as a
dealer sex driver and you know since we
were reading and writing the entire row
at a single point of time we had we get
this great audit ability which allowed
us to catch inconsistency and having no
schema also means that your your child
relations are now flexible
you can do the schema enforcement at
free time finally because we did our own
DevOps having fewer column families
meant fewer column families to maintain
and it was great for us finally a good
query we needed to build financial
reports every night we needed to build
this aggregate queries where we wanted
to tell our financial team what happened
in the previous state and Cassandra
doesn't support aggregate query
basically so what we did we you I talked
about that - a part we took every night
we used that instead and we ran spark
queries on top of high and generated
reports from that now you know not
everyone has a hive data Lake available
but you can use the same scheme you can
write every time you have a write you
can write to another database and do
your aggregate queries from there and we
were actually doing that - we were
replicating write store for real-time
querying as well so you can use
something similar to that
so to recap you can use lightweight
transactions to have consistency because
since this to get that consistency you
can use local Cora mode but local quorum
mode will clobber your rights for
inserts you need to have some sort of
idea what your ID is going to be to do
and if not exists for updates you can
use the version column to do optimistic
locking and remember that you know you
have to retry on any kind of failure and
we dealt with coordinator rights
slightly differently from coordinator
right time or slightly differently than
atomic write theorems not having a
relational schema we've read and wrote
an entire row for
flattened our schema into an entire row
and wrote that finally aggregate queries
are better done elsewhere it it was a
big journey it was a long journey for us
to get here we migrated a system from my
sequel to Cassandra and got massive
scalability in return but we had to
design our application considering all
the trade-offs and then once we've
engineered the application we built
monitoring on top of it so that we could
catch the remaining source set of
problems we started building the system
early January early 2017 and it was
deployed to production in a very limited
form in October 2017 by July 2018 99%
for traffic started running on it
we got great performance we were
processing 2 times the volume in about
half the time we're now available in all
regions and so we achieved a goal of you
know multivision availability we can
write to all reached and we can scale
with Netflix when we began this project
we weren't really sure even internally
at Netflix a lot of people were
skeptical of us building our system on
Cassandra everyone was like really
you're building billing on Cassandra so
there's a lot of skepticism hopefully
I've inspired you to not only see that
it's possible but it's a reality we've
done it so thank you
you